hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast precise detection of t-cell
receptors using RNA C with unique
molecular indexing presented by dr.
Samuel rouille senior global product
manager RNA profiling kaijin I'm Xavier
Gutierrez of lab roots and that will be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring this educational web
seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by kyochon for more
information about our sponsor please
visit
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
anytime you want during the presentation
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and type your questions into the
drop-down box that appears on the screen
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the ask
a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to tenure credits
please join me in welcoming dr. rouille
I will now turn the presentation over to
him
thank you very much Xavier in today's
presentation we're going to talk about
using RNA sequencing to look at and
profile t-cell receptors this is a very
exciting field that has a lot of
different applications some of these
applications revolve around the field of
amino oncology looking at how the immune
system can fight off cancer cells it
also revolves around t-cell development
and immunology in general as well as
different applications from life
sciences through clinical research for
today's presentation I'm going to focus
on one of the techniques for sequencing
t-cell receptors and why you would want
to actually do this within the context
of profiling and immune response
at the legal disclaimer the kits and
products that we are going to present
today are intended for molecular biology
applications these products are intended
for are not intended for the diagnosis
prevention or treatment of disease or up
to the date licensing information and
product specific disclaimers feel free
to download the respective hydrogen kit
handbook or user manual these kit
handbooks and user manuals are available
on chi cheng calm or can be requested
from Kajol Technical Services or your
local disc endure
as an introduction into T cells and P
cell receptors T cells are one of the
many different immune cells that we have
and T cells are very unique in that they
respond and protect us from specific
threats T cells do this by recognizing
specific antigens and complexes using
what's called the T cell receptor T
cells express different receptor genes
and combinations of these receptor genes
determine the affinity for specific
antigens so down here on the bottom of
our screen I've depicted two different
types of T cells these P cells will
respect will express different genes
term the alpha beta or the gamma and
Delta subunit in a particular T cell you
will find that they have either alpha
and beta genes or gamma and Delta chains
when we look at the function of these P
sub receptors they will function as
heterodimers and you will find a
specific alpha and beta subunit or gamma
and Delta subunit
during the formation of these t-cell
receptors there is a dramatic change in
the genomic DNA and it undergoes somatic
recombination the t-cell receptors can
be broken down into what's called the
variable regions and the constant
regions the constant regions are the
same for all t-cell receptors they are
sliced together during RNA transcription
and they are a pretty boring part of the
molecule but when we look at the
variable region this is where the actual
excitement is and it's the variable
region and this variability that allows
P cell receptors to have a tremendous
number of different recombination events
that allow the right recombination event
to recognize a specific antigen within
the DNA cassettes that get recombined
they're termed different names so we
have the B region we have the J region
and we have the D region the alpha and
gamma receptors will use the V and J
regions while the beta and Delta
receptors will use the B D and J regions
when researchers are interested in
looking at the immune repertoire often
they need to think about which
particular type of the t-cell receptors
they want to characterize there's been a
lot of work that's been done over the
last 15 years that is focused on looking
at recombination and the immune
repertoire of just the PC R beta gene
this was done because this was
recognized as one of the more highly
expressed genes we had good ways to
detect this at the DNA level and it
really became the standard for probably
the last 10 or 15 years however recently
with the advent of much better RNA
sequencing kits researchers are now
looking at the complete ramune
repertoire which includes the alpha beta
gamma and delta receptors and in the
experiments that we'll be talking about
today when we define the immune
repertoire we'll be talking about
looking at alpha beta gamma and Delta
genes and trying to look at the
proportion of these and
they change during different conditions
within the different receptors there are
what's called the complementary
determinant regions these are termed CDR
one CDR two and CDR three the
complementary determinant regions are
the parts of the protein that will be in
close contact with the antigen and it's
the CDR one CDR two and CDR three
regions which are thought to determine
the specificity of a receptor for a
particular antigen for the last ten or
fifteen years when we were focusing on
the beta receptor we focus on a very
small part of the variable region termed
the CBR 3 region however with the
sequencing technology that we have today
we can focus on the CBR 3 region or we
can focus on the complete module using
much longer reads so with the
experiments that we're talking about
today we will be using the same RNA
sequencing library kit and determine and
determine and based on how we set up our
sequencing machine we can focus on only
the CBR 3 region of the alpha beta gamma
and Delta subunits or we can focus on
looking at the complete molecule which
gives us the CDR 1 CBR 2 and CDR three
regions
a nice picture of some summary of the
different regions domains is showing
here on the right-hand side of the
screen we have a T cell the T cell is
depicted in pink on the left hand side
here we have an antigen-presenting cell
in between the antigen presenting cell
and the T cell we have the T cell
receptor here we're looking at the beta
chain and the Alpha chain you can see
the constant regions in blue and you can
see the beta sub chain with the CBR 3
region highlighted in between the CDR 3
region and the MHC which is the major
histocompatibility complex on the
antigen presenting cell we have the AG
which is the antigen and what we're
trying to depict here in the top picture
is that it's the CBR 3 region on the
beta chain that is in close contact with
the antigen and knowing the specific
peptide sequence that's there which we
can get from sequencing the RNA to give
us some insight into the peptides that
are determining the affinity for the
antigen one of the exciting things with
knowing what the T cell receptors are is
that you can actually build out a
chimeric artificial t cell that can
express a specific receptor and if you
know what the antigen is maybe something
expressed on the cancer cell you can
actually build a t cell that would be
able to go and identify the antigen and
kill that cancer cell on the bottom of
the screen here we're looking at the
recombination of the DNA to define the
RNA transcript that will be expressed on
the bottom here we have the different VD
and J regions that come together in the
beta subunit there are 54 different B
regions there's a couple of different D
regions and in about 13 different J
regions which can be recombined at the
DNA level these are transcribed into RNA
and then there's a splicing event that
occurs in order for the constant region
to be added back to the recombined bdj
RNA construct when we're using RNA
sequencing what we often do is we
capture the regions starting from the C
region through the JD & B region and
this is the region that we want a
sequence in order to identify either the
CBR 3 region or the complete molecule
based on shorter or longer reads
for sequencing there's been a couple
different technologies that have been
used to identify the t-cell receptors
you can start by sequencing the DNA or
you can start by sequencing the RNA
sequencing the DNA is what a lot of
researchers think up this was one of the
first techniques that was used for
identifying the T cell receptor sequence
a lot of researchers think of using DNA
because these samples are very easy to
obtain we can use biopsy samples from
tissues or we can even go and use
preserved slides on that starting
material DNA tends to be very stable it
tends to not be a damaged as much as RNA
in addition since an individual cell may
have only one copy of a successfully
rearranged bdj event the DNA may reflect
the quantity of receptor better with the
idea that the number of sequences that
you see of a particular receptor
receptor coordinates with the number of
cells that have that successful
recombination and you may be able to
infer the number of P cells or the
relative amount of T cells that are in
that particular sample that you're
starting with starting with RNA is a
much newer approach T cell receptor mRNA
templates are likely to be expressed at
very high levels within the T cell and
we think by starting with RNA this
allows us to get much higher sensitivity
where if you have a small of cells in a
particular population we can still
capture that T cell receptor sequence
this is very important to have high
sensitivity especially for looking at
minimal residual disease or trying to
identify a T cell at a particular time
point that has either been up regulated
before or will be upregulated in the
future with RNA sequencing this allows
us to identify expressed T cell receptor
sequences even though DNA undergoes two
recombination there could be
recombination events that never get
expressed within that particular cell
they can be biological dead ends but by
capturing the RNA we know that this RNA
is going to be expressed and translated
to protein and it referees
it's the true t cell receptor within
that particular cell in addition the
relatively shorter length of T cell
receptor mRNA templates allow for a very
easy library construction method and
allows us to capture the complete vdj
region and this means that we can
identify not only the CBR 3 region but
also the CDR one and the CBR 2 region by
identifying the CDI one and CDR 2 region
this allows us to have the complete
complimentary determinants regions of
the receptor and there is some
interesting biology pointing out that
CDR 1 and CBR 2 to play a particular
role in a number of different diseases
the kit that we use at collagen and that
I'm going to talk about today and the
rest of today's webinar is going to
start with an RNA library seek
preparation in this particular workflow
will start with RNA we will convert it
over to cDNA we'll do some manipulation
of the cDNA is to have to add a unique
molecular index and then complete out
the rna-seq library for sequencing on
the next-gen sequencing instrument to go
through the individual workflow the
first thing that we do is we start with
RNA and then we use a pool of primers
for gene specific reverse transcription
of the alpha beta gamma and delta T cell
receptor mRNAs typically when we start
this particular type of library
preparation we have isolated the RNA
from our starting material for this
particular library there's no need to do
any sort of ribosome reduction or to
enrich for mRNA we can start with the
total RNA either from an enriched t cell
population for instance if we're doing
fluorescently activated or fax sorting
we can go through and take those cells
and pop them open to isolate the RNA or
we can go through and just start with a
fraction of a ppm C or we can take a
tumor Lysa NOPA and look at infiltrating
T cells after the cDNA reaction we're
going to go through and we're going to
clean up the DNA we're going to make
double-stranded DNA we're going to make
the end amendable to doing a ligation
reaction
the next event is to do a ligation
reaction and during this ligation
reaction we're going to add back one of
these sample index adapters within the
sample index adapter there are three
different regions one is a universal
region that we'll use for future PCR
steps another has a sample index in it
that is part of the sample index scores
of sequencing and then another part
shown here in green has a um I or unique
molecular index the kit that we're
talking about today uses unique
molecular indexing as a way to solve for
PCR amplification bias as well as to do
error correction and to know how much of
a library that work sequence if you're
not familiar with unique molecular
indexing this is a technology that is
currently being used in a lot of
different NGS kits for unique molecular
indexing what this does is it allows us
to take a PCR fragment and to give it a
unique molecular barcode and this allows
us to go through and to look at
differences between amplicons based on
these molecular indexing in the example
I'm showing you on this screen here
we're looking at a typical amplicon
sequencing library on the left hand side
you have five replicates of one
transcript and on the right hand side we
have five unique transcripts of a gene
this is what your sequencing machine
sees it sees five red lines four five
replicates of a transcript or five red
lines four five unique transcripts of a
gene it actually can't tell you the
difference whether or not this was one
sequence amplified five times or five
sequences amplified one time however by
adding back the unique molecular index
we can now go through and give each of
these transcripts of its own barcode on
the left-hand side here you can see that
we've used a gray unique molecular index
and we can see that when we go through
and count the number of Gray's we have
one gray so this means that we have five
replicates of one transcript what
probably happened here was that we
captured one molecule and it was
amplified five times during the library
construction on the right hand side here
we can you can see that we have five
different colors for our unique
molecular index what happened here is
that we captured five different our name
skills and we sequenced each one one
time so by adding back unique molecular
index we can go through and we can use
this as a very quantitative way for
amplicon sequencing we can count the
situation out left we count up the
number of unique molecular indexes as
one on the right hand side we can see
now that we have five different
molecules that are there
so by using uniqua let your indexing
what this allows us to do is really to
make targeted sequencing more accurate
and more precise around the
quantification of the number of
molecules that we're sequencing in
addition unique molecular indexing can
also help us go through and look at the
ability of detecting rare variants or
rare transcripts that are there and
separate things out from either PCR
library construction or sequencing
artifacts in this particular example
here we're looking at the t-cell
receptor beta sequence you can see here
I've aligned the reads that are they're
shown here with a red asterisk is one
read that has a different nucleotide
sequence than the rest of these tips
when we go through and we build our
libraries we use both enzymatic as well
as other methods of amplifying the RNA
to see DNA and the DNA throughout the
library construction there are places
where enzymes no matter how high
fidelity they are can introduce an
artificial error so in this particular
instance here if we were to go back and
look at this where we see a one
nucleotide difference we really don't
often know whether this is a PCR
sequencing artifact or is this actually
a true low-frequency sequence that's
there a unique clonal type that may
actually be the secret to finding cancer
by adding the unique molecular indexes
before we do any amplification we can go
through and align all of the sequences
that have the same um I and actually go
through and do error correction on the
sequencing and PCR steps during library
construction so at the bottom here we
have sequencing with the UM I on the
left hand side the screen you can see we
have the yellow um I and when we align
all the sequences that came from that
you can see that only one of the
sequences has the red asterisk or the
red nucleotide difference so that
indicate to that the sequencing error
whereas on the right hand side you can
see that the um I the red um I all of
the sequences have the same red asterisk
which means that that's actually a true
nucleotide that was sequence there when
we add the um is before any
amplification any downstream artifacts
that are introduced can actually be
removed giving you much higher quality
data in addition when we do our data
analysis we can now introduce unique
ways to filter the data so in
experiments that we often do we want to
make sure that we have both biological
and technical reproducibility across
this so often when we go through we look
at our final data we need to make sure
that we only click monotypes
where we have three um eyes which means
we have three separate capture events or
we captured three separate RNA molecules
and then we can go through and count the
number of times we sequence each
individual umi so if we go through and
we say we need a cuomo type that has
three um eyes and as the sequence only
three times that means that we have nine
independent observations that that is
actually a true sequence and this is one
of the ways that we can bring much more
accuracy to identifying rare t-cell
receptors
in addition when we do sequencing a lot
of times when we build these libraries
we actually don't sequence the entire
library often with RNA sequencing we
don't know how many copies of a
particular transcript were looking at
and we need to guess how many reads we
need to use for a particular library
this can often lead to either over
sequencing or under sequencing if we
over sequence a particular library the
more sequencing you do the more chance
you have of incorporating an air into
the transcript that you're looking at in
addition if you under sequence a library
you actually didn't look at all the data
that's there and you can actually have a
very important piece of the puzzle
missing one of the things that we do
with the um is is that we can gauge
whether or not we've sequenced all the
modules that we put on to the sequencing
machine we can look at the mean reads
per um I if we see that the mean read
per um I is somewhere around five that
means that we sequence every um I at
least five times and that is usually a
good indication that the entire library
that we put on the sequencing machine
has been sequence meaning that we didn't
leave any of the data to be discovered
one of the examples of this is shown
here with the verification plots that we
use in our data analysis with a
refutation plot we can actually
mathematically predict the of potential
receptors that were there and then we
can overlay this with the actual
sequencing data to see how much of that
potential immune repertoire we covered
in the sample that we're looking at
after we've added back our unique
molecular index through that ligation
reaction now it's time to complete the
rest a lot to capture the gene specific
P cell receptor alpha beta gamma and
Delta sequences we use a gene specific
or primers this allows us to go through
and to hone in and to have a very
targeted panel this allows us also to
dedicate most of the reads during that
sequencing run to identifying the novel
alpha beta gamma and Delta subunits you
have there
then we do a quick bead cleanup we then
move to the sample indexing to add back
the last sample index using a simple PCR
reaction we do one final bead cleanup
and then we have a sequencing ready
library we typically quantitate this
using either PTR method a bio analyzer
or some other method to look at both the
size distribution as well as the
quantity of the library that we have
once we've done that we can then move on
to denaturing and loading this on to a
next-gen sequencing instrument
you
as part of a complete workflow kaijin
we've put together a sample to inside
solution so for sample isolation we
typically start with isolating RNA if
we're starting with salted tissue this
would be an RDC kit if we're starting
with blood samples this will be the pax
gene RNA isolation kit for the mRNA
enrichment we have two different types
of kits that we develop we have a kit
for starting with human t-cells and we
have a kit for starting with Mouse T
cells for sample indexing we have
several different solutions these depend
on the number of samples and the type of
sequencing machine that you're going to
use shown here are the solutions for
using an Illumina next-gen sequencing
machine we have a 12 index kit which
allows you to run 12 samples together at
one time and then we also have a 96
index kits both the ABC and D version
which will allow you to run up to 384
samples in the single lane on Illumina
sequencing machine the library QC we
often use a qPCR method that is very
accurate for the complete library being
constructed for next-gen sequencing run
we often run this on either a my seat
next week high-speed or other
illuminated sequencing platforms and
then for bioinformatics what we do is we
developed out a web-based tool where you
can upload your off fast queue file the
web-based tool we'll go through will
interpret the sequencing information and
then give you a final report it will
tell you how many receptors what type of
receptor the nucleotide sequence of the
receptor the protein sequence of the
receptor and then the cloner type based
on international standards
the next couple of slides are going to
go through some performance data and
application data that we've generated
here to show you how we are typically
using the kit for the first example of
the performance data these this is on an
experiment that was done in
collaboration with a group of
researchers where we took and looked at
the concordance of t-cell Crono typing
using a fax or fluorescently activated
cell sorting with antibodies versus what
you would see when you use to RNA
sequencing data in this particular
experiment we're sorting p cells the T
cells that are being sorted first they
will be sorted for T cells and then they
will be chronotype to using antibodies
and this will tell us the type of t-cell
receptors that are there some of the T
cells that were sorted and we're not
gonna type for used and we isolated RNA
from them we built our any site
sequencing libraries using 10 nanograms
or 25 milligrams of total RNA which
represents about a thousand or 2,500 T
cells here I'm summarizing the data on
the left hand side here we have the fax
data and then we have the 10 nanograms
and the twenty five nanograms and what
I'm showing you here is the cloner type
so we have the BB from the beta chain 3
with the corne type shown there and then
the numbers are the percentages of that
clone o type in that particular sample
so for example in the first line here we
have the TR beta be 28 core o type and
we saw that this was 33% of the T cells
in the facts panel 30 percent of the
cells using RNA sequencing and 10
nanograms and about 35 percent of the
total population using twenty five
nanograms in pink here what I've done is
to highlight that the major clonal types
that were discovered using the fax
machine we're confirmed with RNA
sequencing and that there is a very high
concordance between both of the methods
we see that we get very similar
percentages of those cono types that are
identified by facts are sown in RNA
sequencing and that the complete immune
repertoire can be characterized by RNA
sequencing and in
very similar to what you would be doing
with facts as we dug down deeper into
the data we started looking at plots
that look like this what we're looking
at here is the correlation again of the
T cell sequencing versus the cytometry
on the y-axis here we have the T cell
receptor beta where we're focusing only
on the beta change here where we're
looking at the count using the unique
molecular index and we're comparing this
to the frequencies by using the fact
sorting on the x axis here you can see
the linear line here which is showing us
the concordance in red we are
identifying or actually on the bottom of
the screen here we're looking here at
three different Colonna types that had
antibody cross-reactivity these
particular clone types are very similar
in their peptide sequence and it's been
known for a while that these antibodies
who are very promiscuous and will not
identify these as a single clone o type
but rather as a pool we didn't see these
present in the RNA sequencing data this
is most likely because the RNA
sequencing data is looking at the
particular sequences that are there and
we're not fooled by antibodies not
working properly close on the x axis
here we identified five of these
different dots in red these are five
novel chrono types that we are
identified with RNA sequencing that were
not able to be identified using the fax
method because there are no antibodies
available to identify these particular
chrono types what are the advantages of
switching from a fax method over to an
RNA sequencing method especially for
discovery research is that we can go
through and discover all the clonal
types that are there which can actually
lead us in new avenues or help us
stratify the samples that we're looking
at a little bit differently
we recently took this data and put
together a publication that was looking
at the T cell analysis of two baths and
shared melanoma samples where we're
looking at the common commonality as
well as specific features of a couple of
different populations and in this paper
that was done with a collaboration with
Sylvan Simon and Napoli labarie from
INSERM and University of Nantz we went
through and we looked at the concordance
between facts data as well as with the
targeted RNA sequencing kit that we're
talking about today and we saw very high
concordance and if you're interested in
looking at the experiments and repeating
these you can download this open access
paper and see how it was one
one of the questions that we often get
when we're looking at P sub receptors is
how sensitive is the detection or can I
really find a needle in a haystack with
a lot of the methods that are based
around cell counting and self's warning
we're looking at individual cells and
the fluorescence intensity which is
often proportional to the number of
receptors on the surface of that
particular T cell and we can often go
through and look at the data and say we
had a certain proportion of receptors
that were positive or negative for
different types of markers with this
next performance data I'm going to
present here what we're looking at is
the ability to identify a particular T
cell receptor in the background of
normal PBMCs so what we started with
were two donors of normal with normal
PBMCs we're looking at just a normal
blood draw here and we put two donors
together to really increase the
diversity of the samples that we're
looking at and then we took the jurkat
cell line the jerk ATS online is a T
cells clonal cell line that we can grow
up in our laboratory the T cell jurkat
cell line that we're using has one known
alpha beta clone and then we did a spike
in experiment we would start with eight
million of these cells
eight million cells from our donors from
our PBMC and then add back different
percentages of the jurkat cell and the
idea is can we detect 1% 0.1% point zero
one percent of the jerk at t cell
receptor in the background of these
PBMCs
we built RNA sequencing libraries with a
different amounts of PBMCs
so what I'm showing you here is on the
y-axis the percentages and then I'm
showing you two different bars here I'm
showing you the reads that map back to
the t-cell receptor and then the reads
that are usable for chronotype calling
and then on the x-axis here we're
looking at the input of the PBMC RNA
we're looking at the complete immune
repertoire here not focusing on an
individual sequence with the RNA
sequencing library kit we can see that
90% of the total reads will map back the
t-cell receptor alpha beta gamma or
Delta gene which has very high
specificity and accuracy of the kit
which allows you to get the most out of
the number of samples that you're
running at one time however about 65% of
the total reads are usable for the bdj
chromo typing the other briefs that we
throw away often contain introns in the
spliced variants when we're going
through and you think about the life
cycle of RNA you have RNA that is
transcribed and then it goes through
several processing steps before it's
transformed into ml RNA which will
actually be translated into protein when
you're doing RNA sequencing you actually
do capture on spliced RNA that would be
resident within nucleus or has been just
released from the nucleus into the
cytoplasm and when we capture those
unbiased or RNAs that are truncated we
can't use those for cono type calling
here we're looking at the duplicate of
building different libraries by
different technicians this is to show
the robustness of the kit if you build
different libraries on different days or
different technicians build the same
libraries you should get a very linear
correlation between that and that's
exactly what we see with the t-cell
receptor here what we're looking at in
the top are two thousand clones that
were called with the two different
libraries and then on the bottom here
what we're looking at is the top two
thousand clones where we've really
loomed into that blob that you see
around the XY axis to show that you see
a very linear correlation when you run
the same samples with different
libraries which is very important if
you're trying to do reproducible science
the next couple of slides here are going
through and looking at the dilution
experiment and looking at tracking the
alpha and beta subunits of the jerk app
this is to show you that the jerk app
clone could be detected in all the
different samples down to point zero one
percent and that the jerk at clone
abundance is highly correlated with the
number of the jurkat cells that we've
started with this is to confirm the
earlier observations that we showed that
RNA sequencing is very quantitative and
that the expression levels that you see
of the colon type is proportionate to
the number of cells that you have there
this is very important when you're
looking at trying to identify maybe the
number or the whether a t-cell is
infiltrating into a particular sample
the more color types you see the more of
that cells that are there within that
sample lastly we've gone through and we
started to summarize some of the data
that you'll see in the report that you
get out of our t-cell receptor data
analysis porno that we have on cryogen
comm what I'm summarizing here are the
top clones so we're looking at the
t-cell receptor alpha based on the
percentages of the jurkat and the rank
within that particular sample we have
the clone o type that was called there
and then in the right hand side we have
the number of raw reads and then we have
the number of unique molecular indexes
that are there you can see that in the
first sample this is where we had 10%
jurkat spike in to the 8 million
that were there we had 750 1000 reaps
that aligned back to this and then we
had one hundred and seven thousand um I
remember that the unique molecular index
is the number of times we capture an
unique molecule while the reads are the
total number of times that we'll
rereading the same sample so in this
particular example each individual um I
was on average read about seven times
meaning that we have very high
confidence in the sequence that we're
looking at as we look and we dilute down
the jerk at sell more and more we can
see that when we get down to point zero
one percent the t-cell receptor alpha is
now the tenth most abundant receptor
within that population we have 1,300
reads with 217 um eyes meaning that
we're reading there one molecule over
multiple times and when we look at the
beta chain we see very similar data we
can see that we can identify the t-cell
receptor beta down to point zero one
percent which gives us 457 reads with 60
um eyes one of the common questions that
we get around the um eye technologies
that music hydrogen is how many um is do
you really need to see have high
confidence in the particular data set
that you're looking at and often if we
read the same um I three to five times
we have very high confidence that that's
actually a true sequence and it's a true
molecule that we captured during the RNA
sequencing library so it's not necessary
to see the same molecule hundreds or
thousands of times but if we see a um I
and we sequence at five times we believe
that's a true sequence in our experiment
next slide here that we're looking at is
a visualization of the t-cell receptor
in the background so in the upper left
hand corner here we're looking at the
10% jerk at that on the y axis there
we're looking at the percentages so that
tall bar there is the jerk on v-j paired
that is being expressed there in s2 is
the 1% jerk at and here you can still
see that one tall bar that we see in the
10% jerk at but now you're starting to
see some of the other clonal types that
are there present in the donor blood
that we use when we get down the point
zero one percent it's very difficult now
to pull up the jerk at sequence that
we're looking at here you can see now
it's blended in the background and now
we're seeing more the diversity that was
contributed by the donor cells when you
look at a normal milliliter of blood out
of most humans you can see anywhere from
thousand from a thousand to ten thousand
different color types that are there
based on one of the person was healthy
or sick and based on some other
exposures to different types of features
one of the interesting things about
looking at the t-cell receptor and
overlaying this with other parts of
parts of information is that this is a
very important field that is emerging
for a lot of researchers that are
focusing on Tamim oncology one of the
things that we're doing at kaijin is
focusing not only on looking at the
immune repertoire but time the immune
repertoire into gene expression as well
as looking at mutational burden so one
of the focuses in our immune or ecology
programs that we have here is the focus
on overlaying different types of
information today we talked about
looking at the immune repertoire by
using archive see community rep ATAR RTC
t cell receptor panel in the future will
present some data looking at both a gene
expression panel where we can look at
amino ecology which looks at checkpoint
inhibitors and other types of gene
expression and genes that drive tumor
progression as well as looking at the
state of the T cells and then we'll
override this with looking at DNA
mutations using a tumor mutation verdict
a tune towards more information as we
get closer to you are talking about
these models lastly I'd like to thank
everybody for attending our presentation
today I see that there's some questions
here so we'll jump into the
question-and-answer session and again
thank you for your attention
you
thank you doctor really for that
informative presentation we're now start
the Q&A portion of the webinar and we'll
address some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
our speaker will follow up with your
questions via email let's get started
our first question is how many reads do
you recommend per sample that's a very
good question we've tried to develop our
kids to be as flexible as possible to
see a whole bunch of different research
scenarios that you see in either the
same lab or common laps that may be
interested in collaborating so for a
discovery experiment where we're going
through and we just want to see the top
maybe hundred two thousand clones that
we might use a million reads per sample
for experiments where we want to take a
deep dive into a sample and see all the
cool know types that are there we might
use anywhere from five to ten million
reads per sample
and what is the cost of the data
analysis can I run my own analysis
the cost of the data analysis is built
into the cost of the kit so it's
basically free once you've bought the
kit if you want to run your own data
analysis using the gene web web portal
is very easy to use you can log into the
website to create yourself a space on
there this is free to do and then once
you upload your fat skew data you push a
couple of buttons to say how you did the
sequencing instrument that you did and
which files you want to analyze and it
will start the process and then when
it's done it will alert that you're done
and you can download your report if you
want to run your own analysis the
analysis pipeline that we set up is it's
very transparent on how we set it up and
we can assist you with understanding how
we do the UM ID multiplexing and then
you could incorporate this into your own
pipeline for your own results in case
you need to put this on your own servers
for some sort of IT reason or by our IT
security issues or you would just like
to go through and change some of the
filters to take advantage of the
sequencing data that you have
are we able to match the alpha and beta
receptors or delta and gamma receptors
common question that we get when we're
talking about using this particular kit
and unfortunately we're not able to do
any matched receptors with this kit
we're focusing on looking at the immune
repertoire which is looking at the total
diversity of the sample in order to go
through and to match alpha and beta or
gamma and Delta receptors you often have
to use a single cell kit and get down to
the single cell level sequence those out
and then by natural of having a single
cell you'll be able to match two
receptors
and their last question do you have any
solutions to work with single cells from
a fax sort that's also a very good
question
from a fax or we're typically going
through we can capture single cells once
we have those single cells we have
developed out a kit that allows you to
actually capture the entire
transcriptome from that sample we call
the kit the kayo seek FX single-cell RNA
kit
it starts with yourself it undergoes a
license of the cell we amplified the RNA
we actually make cDNA and then amplify
the cDNA and once we made the cDNA we
build a library from start to finish
it's about three hours of time to build
your library and then you're on to
sequencing when you're using a
sequencing machine it takes you usually
overnight to get the data and then for
data analysis you can typically run this
through any sort of RNA sequencing
pipeline and you can focus on the T cell
receptor sequences as well as going
through and understanding the gene
expression or any other type of RNA
sequencing data point you'd like to look
at
well I would like to once again thank
dr. Rui for his presentation I'd also
like to thank Arjun for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through January of
2019 you will receive an email from
librarians letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that's all for now thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon goodbye